welcome back true crime stories are more  popular than ever and that interest has  spread across tv  books podcasts and now there's this new  app it's called crime door  it allows viewers to revisit famous  crimes like the murder of jonbenet  ramsey  and rapper biggie smalls using augmented  reality  and that allows you to open basically a  magical doorway  in your living room and you can walk  into the crime scene  as it was when the detectives were there  interesting so each case is assembled  based on news reports and crime scene  images  features over 700 cases about 65 percent  of them are still unsolved  the app is free to download costs about  two dollars though to open each crime  door very